let's
let's go next
to um
[Music]
let's go to paul garcia from mexico
paul welcome
all right can you hear me yes i can oh
okay uh we've been uh you've been
talking about uh
how abortion and
gun control can
activate democrats vote do you think a
trump associate indictment can activate
republicans to vote
you know maybe to some degree but not
really in the sense that when it comes
to the gun safety issue and roe v wade
and democrats being activated it's
because democrats want to change those
things by voting for different people
although certainly there will be
trumpists who might hear oh this trump
associate was indicted or whatever
um who are they going to vote for i mean
it's like
voting for your local
member of congress isn't really going to
do anything related to that in any kind
of direct way
so i don't think it will engage and and
kind of involve people and excite them
in the same way no
do you think in like a
texas where the
the republican governor is really
dumb and
you know everything is going the wrong
way do you think we're going to see a
big change
like blue wave
i think there's no evidence right now
that that's what's going to happen i
mean you did see you know if you look at
biden versus trump in texas in 2020 it
was the closest margin
for a presidential race
in texas for a while i don't remember
exactly when but but for a while
and so i do think texas is becoming more
purple but i don't expect a blue any
overwhelming blue wave in texas in the
next few years no
okay no thank you all right no problem
there's paul from mexico good good
question appreciate that
who doesn't love a good cereal the
crunchiness the sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right without the
sugar and without a ton of carbs they
have flavors like cocoa honey nut fruity
peanut butter maybe you want to go
adventurous they've got blueberry muffin
maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
i love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but i know it's about to become
your new favorite cereal you'll get five
dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman the link is down below